Speaker 1: Well, you know, every once in a while
it does happen that a guest cancels on us at the
last second. And we had two choices today. Choice
number one would have been cancel the show,
throw the show in the toilet, flush it 10 to
15 times. No show. The other option is let's
open the phone lines very briefly and hear
from just a few people in our audience. And,
you know, I like people in the audience more
or less as much as I like our guests. So it
seems like a very good alternative. Let's
do this via discord, which you can find
at David Pakman dot com slash discord. And I
don't even want to wait anymore. Let's just go
right in and start with Mike from southeastern
Pennsylvania. Mike, we've got the Oz Fetterman
debate tonight. I know you'll be watching.
Speaker 3: Oh, yes, I will.
Speaker 1: Yeah. What are you expecting?
Speaker 3: Uh, I think they're going to probably
pick on Letterman for his health conditions.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I think so. But that's my
question to you. What was on your mind, Mike?
Speaker 3: Oh, I was wondering, why don't they
pass a stamp tax to raise revenue? That's not
tax possible, like for, like, corporate jets or
yachts or something. Thank you. Sorry.
Speaker 1: Did you say a stamp tax?
Speaker 3: Yeah. Pass the stamp
tax. Various luxury or excise items.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So stamp taxes are basically
sometimes they're called duties. That's duty. Why?
They are taxes on specific types of property
purchases. I mean, don't there already are a
bunch, right? Like isn't there like a yacht tax
and a or is that state I guess I don't know enough
about it to know what's currently in place.
Speaker 3: Oh yeah. I just noticed the
inflation is really high for luxury
items so cramped clamped out there.
And why not just pass more duty taxes?
Speaker 1: Well, but I don't know that
the big concern is that luxury goods that a tiny
portion of people can afford are expensive. My
instinct was more as a way to increase government
revenue. It would be something to look at. Right?
Or why? Why would you be looking to do it?
Speaker 3: Yeah. To increase revenue. And
it also would save the post office. It would
create like a substantial collection market that
people would probably collect the stamps.
Speaker 1: Oh, boy. I think we have some
confusion. Generally speaking, when people talk
about a stamp tax, it's not about collectible
stamps. It's a tax on a particular type of item.
Speaker 3: Oh, I know, but I say just create
create stamps or create nonfungible tokens,
something that people can trade with.
Speaker 1: Just you're literally saying
make stamps that people can collect.
Speaker 3: Oh, yeah, absolutely.
Speaker 1: Oh, my goodness. Mike, I don't know
if you're serious, but I appreciate the call.
Speaker 3: Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right. Very good. Was
that was that a joke? I can't even tell.